dès le vendredi 15 octobre les
établissements scolaires ont rendu
hommage à samuel pâti comme au collège
jean zay à verneuil sur seine lors d'un
cours d'histoire géographie et
d'enseignement moral et civique une
classe de 3e a travaillé sur deux thèmes
de réflexion nous avions décidé de nous
intéresser plus particulièrement à ce
que fait le professeur d'histoire
géographie qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce
qu'on apprend en histoire géographie et
pourquoi on étudie l'histoire géographie
samuel tu fais mardi à jamais de notre
communauté
les ai donc ghisi dans notre collège
danton collège annuel il nous semble
évident que deux gros matches c'est au
collège du bois donne de conflans sainte
honorine qu'une grande cérémonie
d'hommage à samuel pâte y était organisé
à huis clos samedi 16 octobre
professeurs personnels éducatifs et
élèves ont pris la parole le ministre de
l'éducation nationale était sur place un
sentiment d'avoir de solidarité avec la
famille de sa vie la fatigue mais
s'accroche avec ses collègues avec ses
élèves et tous les professeurs de france
aussi est au fond avec tous les français
et ce que sont les français qui le jour
récemment il ya un an était totalement
bouleversé par ce qui s'est passé et
quand il ya une mort aussi tragiquement
aussi absurde c'est notre unité qui lui
permet elle qui permet de lui donner un
sens à l'issue de ce premier hommage une
marche blanche est partie du collège
jusqu'à la place de la liberté un
discours a été donné par le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine ému par
l'événement le 16 octobre 2020 restera
un jour à jamais marquée d'une pierre
blanche dans l'histoire de conflans
sainte honorine je pense que le son de
cet hommage c'est à la fin d'un âge
assez mal bâti et en même temps un
moment de rassemblement
indispensable pour qu'on puisse en
ensemble échanger et discuter est resté
soudé en monument en forme des livres
ouverts a été également dévoilé symbole
de la liberté d'expression des centaines
de personnes étaient présentes
c'est vraiment très peu lamentable
pour un chacun sait faire d'ailleurs on
pourra pas l'oublier non plus apporter
eux
mons tient un soutien moral surtout à la
famille à la commune
et tous les conflanais dont je fais
partie un square a également été nommé
samuel pâti en face de l'université la
sorbonne à paris